oh [ __ ], when i think
about it, i once knocked out a discount on
tik tok, which in principle enabled me to rent a whole house,
totally
normal going on, you also jerry fragrance i
think if you google a bit
daniel schütz born in oldenburg
and then you were already there  relatively early so
interested i believe in school
theater but a performance that tells the boy band
why start i've
always done business and creativity
at the same time i already did
tanz theater
theater ag as a youth and did stuff like that
and i've already
watched youtube  made videos at the time and was
then scout and studied for a boy band at the same
time but then I founded a GmbH
in the booty because we had to
make the income somehow blah blah blah
blah blah everything was uninteresting but
somehow with the scents it started like that
when I  was in america and was
in a comment for the first time and was
surprised by this marketing
like everything  so dark loud music horny
guys and girls and a horny smell and
then i noticed it you know how
to dress as much as
but how to style your hair but
you don't know how to fix
it and stuff and so i'm not
somehow born in a lavender field
or a cool story behind it but
very basic where and there i shot one two
three youtube videos and who
wants something what was there i say hello
actually not that young so 24 when
i started youtube with fragrances
and yes that  The third video then went viral
and I was like I said humble
conditions crisis a first payout
from google of
371 euros or so then you say yes every day
I can now spend ten
euros of it for eating one meal a day
awesome and then you lay blood and get it  so
on and I can only
recommend that to anyone who wants
to get influenza do the stupid job first continue
doing a boring job and
parallel this cool sac  hey on youtube
or something and then if that works
then it can distance you more and more
from your thing because i also did
my youtube thing for two years before
i said thats enough i will be jamie
france i will be the machine and i
really went in and  so and
now I'm in the sixth year so I
did two years as a hobby 30 today
then I started when I was 26 I'm
now 33 won
so I like I've been doing it for
almost seven years now
I've done it as a hobby for the first two years
in  fourth year i created my
brand we were a world record on
kickstarter with crowd funding
yes and then we have been
making millions of euros in sales for two three years now good
second brand is dying to do it
again fragrance one fragrance one and
that thing today you do with the total work of
art  case went with the
with the procedure so in frannz man there
are different scents you can make
several million sales ma  n say
exactly and worldwide so it's
somehow you don't sell to
germany and to the whole world i
have a warehouse in new jersey for canada
australia america and a warehouse in
holland for the whole european union and
everything that works so where do you live i live
i  would say in miami because i
have two apartments but i am a
german citizen but
i would think it would be coolest if i lived in miami
on the ocean drive on the beach it doesnt fit
yes we all want to be everywhere somehow
i can even live in kenya as
influenza  and since i haven't started a
family yet, i've always killed myself
a bit, where
did they go now in
oldenburg my hometown bought me a house there
because i'm not stupid
to spend everything at once and
so there a bit  think about it okay i'm
coming back to my home country where i was
little and didn't have anything you
do that but then three four five months max oh
no that's it  not like that you have to
grow and
you may
know oldenburg never says to yourself that's not new
york city and that's not the
ocean either so neither business nor the
people nor the healthy lifestyle is
the only thing there is
self-fulfilment that you  you made
it and according to the motto but you were
always a very performance type so
now this theater ag has to get the house
and then you were actually in the
boy band there you would be cast
and so you understood early on how
it works attention with
stage  with doing things and only then that
at some point youtube licked blood with
dad so really coincidentally you
really weren't a spa before junkie
or not somehow the son of a professional
moerser but somehow by
chance you smelled it came into your closet and
told her okay now i'll do it now  sometimes and
then it went off exactly that's right
that was absolutely
yes the success tasted blood, so to speak,
so I thought  That's cool and that's it.
I did it as a hobby for two years
. I think it's cool to talk about fragrances
and probably here and then every three
weeks
there is
actually somehow the perfume type there
is karl lagerfeld there is
arnold Schwarzenegger alter but who
is there that i should say cherry
fritz he should mention what i have
meanwhile somehow am so
that deposit you have the
following how much on youtube  the 24 x 7 4
10 7 3 million youtube stratec
3.4 million on instagram half a
million half a million yes, of course that
means in total there will
certainly be millions of
coverage if you if you normally make the
video somehow finished
probably after night  if it has
n't
cracked a hundred thousand after two days, it's gone, that
's it, unfortunately, you have to
the viewers say you put your
whole heart into it and sometimes you do
n't know what works and
that you have to have your skin that's
why i want a lot because i
don't know what works i
can only shoot my videos a great
mood and then you two know  days
later what flops what doesn't if you
do them too let's say things that
are very unusual besides the scents
do you also give nutritional tips
for then says somehow
i wrote one down
i have to be really healthy the mackerel
for breakfast was it i think  so
exactly how many films not for
breakfast well i only now
have three because the other half
of the bread is covered with ham here
because otherwise it is too little too much of the
fed and yes and i noticed it is
so cool i feel old i am a
ate a bit of deer age
is like that
[laughter]
well and at the same time he is testing that
and that is currently testing me a lot, for example
Fasting is irritating and three things
have totally changed my life, so
cold showers, green tea and fasting and
you are helping me to fast with this
invitation because I have been
doing
36 hours once a week for almost two months now,
but I started two weeks ago in
Ibiza  where it was super easy
two full days that means i don't eat
anything for two full days and actually
three days a week
and
i noticed ibiza where i was now awesome sun i'm
lying up there without really awesome like you
good friends then i was there
fasted for two days now in the dreary
rain and so the super heavy thing so we
mustn't forget the whole internet but
also the surroundings of us
I'll give you that as a
tip as well we need sun people so if
it's possible take a look so that you get some sun
and  out best from
Germany if not little asks
out to the equator here where do
most people live the longest
cos  ta rica sardinia and somehow
panama and so well we have to
definitely repositioned itself
but also its power yes content yes
also in english so everything you
do you have decided whether actually
what yes but never longer than in so than
as a student or  didn't live in england as a child
and you don't say do it
with the german school english
then really you've become a
star in china too i think
insolvent pakistan there is christan yes
because if you show up there somehow
it's always your fault that's a
lot  surprising because all these
countries like india and pakistan are
all getting internet now i read something
six years ago or something that by
2024 the whole world will have internet
that means you big hams like india
or pakistan or brazil they
all have internet and they love it  also
fragrances as you know or about i
don't know and yes since chris of course many
viewers they are super great vo  ll and
what struck me there in
pakistan they all have a mobile phone even the
poorest strata many of them have a
mobile phone so it's really essential and
but only a sign at the
end in english is ready everything can be done
that's okay  german does
n't really do anything but i have a german
channel but it doesn't do me any good
and never was germany never appealed to me that
much as a child so close
motto i want a cooler i want to have an
apartment in munich or something nope i
have than  kid arnold Schwarzenegger
seen movies or bad boys with
hereby what's his name wants smith or pdf
workgroup mtv so i thought that was cool old
american pie i want to be babbel held
and well you'll be brought as a
kid what you want to have later
as an adult and that  it's also one of
the things that
's also so common, so what
would you be interested in? would you
like to say that you're going to do it for the
next few decades  n so you can
or is that a vision are you thinking
about in october where do i want to go
what should i have something the next
type be and stay and forever
the brand germany france yes
so to speak into the pension magazine goal i
need that  young crazy wild guys
who film and stuff like that i
actually still do it as a
one man show and just
the big ones how big is his company currently
and do you have employees i have no
employees so what actually i have
all the employees
but they pay them  I actually only like that
and expenses with the company but
at the same time when I need them they also
help me hoops
several million sales without
[music]
that you people because a shop in a shop
namely as a shop and it's not the
art I can do it now  like louis
vuitton
i go to
www.diw.deliefert was.de now i give
a rather protein shakes to the kindergarten
but for all those who want to make the new election as a present
if you mi  ch now fast
horse the easiest way to
earn money look for a girl who has
millions of followers has the good body
has the hot moms anti shake who
delivers was.de protein producers ok
produce for two euros 10 protein a
kilo sell for 119 euros the two
million followers
director consumer okay we sell like
19 euros ourselves for two years ten white ones
and then you sold it directly
while a few if not
cheaper a few companies like that
cost something that the fraggles one fragrance
one sometimes costs 300 euros on
average  so the office starts at 160
to the black tie at 319 but it's
not the art of producing a fragrance for seven euros
10 anyone can
do that i just wanted to say even with now
not with a protein shake there is
sometimes your price but with
luxury products viennese louis
vuitton handbags which we can also imitate
the quality of the wars are the quality of louis
vitton hink  riegen has been heard 1000 times or
the hermès quality but stupidly they bought the
brand and people also buy
the brand from me but also the quality
sometimes what do you have for
production costs if you
leave a helper so factor 10 with me
so you have produced  what for do
n't know 5 euros or 3 euros before and then
you can sell it sometimes
coaching that was 130 30 goal factor much
much higher so if you only if you have a
product factor 5 that means you
produce 14 sell it for 50 to
cool  if you have a factor of 10 it's still cool
so i'll produce for
seven euros 20 is also variable doesn't
sell 300 euros the shipping costs
of five euros and the rest goes into
your pocket so pay attention a marshall is
possible yes 80 percent profit i had
yes  also with here i know the
crazy wall street
billionaires because i did a few push-
ups kick off here in all these
events and how we got from you
i  in new york someone 15-year-old
does push-ups and that's exactly where i
've experienced a few pitches
and if that's the case with the estée lauder
owner leonard lauder with whom
you'll get in pretty quickly if
you have the number ears in your  industry in
america vista
and but started they are into
profits is not just a review but
profit is important that is very
briefly to understand the history
so we know where you come from
you now know some of them have
landed you in between was when it
started  first of all so that you made a lot of
money so you then
recommended other performance via
your youtube channel you
got commission on how much money
business then also
know about influenza other fits so recommended by big
fragrance brands and then at some point
i decided  do my own thing
exactly, first of all I might have
criticized that you
still call yourself jerry frame  s sometimes 25,000
euros for a tick tock video war
now from the big companies
because they say okay the guy has as many
ratings as pirates of the caribbean
we pay that too as i know
they did tv advertising
before when i did  so knowing
the next one was on the way well and no
i said at some point okay what should i do
now i am talking for the
hundredth time about bleu de chanel and
for the 200th time about the osser what should i
work for dior should i
buy a theory or should i  make mine
branded and i
said okay i put mine in and
would the procedure be done at the end well
you are not a perfume alberto
morillas my favorite perfumer
fortunately i always talked very well
about him i then edited
them together these clips sent them to you  and he
said i'll make some air for the little guy
because he has a free hand
at l'oréal he is  the party more from
gucci and he makes his first
most successful palfinger the sg where he
lived experienced also in geneva in switzerland
the man lives but he is over 70 and he
just does it for fun and of course
a scent made and you have the
weekend  okay that's cool and
that with yes that's not even like
I said it's cool I've done
several reworks it's like
when a michael jackson or let's say
dieter bohlen a song for you
he doesn't do it  good enough no it's
still a bit too long
he needs to be a bit louder
says i did it about 17
times with his creation until i
said 'come on now that suits the other
companies because they just aren't as
handy as me because that
employees are just like that saying okay this
scent that fits for the quarter of
2015 come back we'll release it
said no dude that my own money
and say i'll do another one completely until
we perfect  that means
my fragrances are not made by me
but from the best papers in the world
and i only sell them on my
website without the people who
can test them over we
knocked on her door for the simplicity of trading so it would be
clear i was with i was  everywhere at
macy's at the headquarters in new york city
or i don't even know if the
headquarters i was at douglas in
düsseldorf and they want them only
it's not revealing any secrets it's
clear they want to earn some money from it
and then you pay  I don't mind
no scent costs 100 euros let's say
but you sell it for
[music]
20 euros but why should I
sell the Danes for 20 euros the 80 on it why
can't I somehow sell them myself
for 100 I can do it
then you could sell more and
go, yes, that's true, that's what i
thought now too, i'm finding it right now,
but only in countries where it's difficult for me to
get in, for example you  bai there i
'm talking to golden cent right now or you've
already placed the first order whether you're chatting with me yourself
without making any noise
and
trust that saudi arabia to middle
east because to saudi arabia from holland
the number up to 56 euros shipping costs and
then  he also pays another 50 euros
import tags and you have the same problem
with russia you have the same problem with
brazil and mexico because they don’t
want you to get his luxury
goods in with them so you need a
strong local partner who doesn’t
fool you and but that works  nowadays
so ron people don't care because
douglas or you say it doesn't make any sense
because that germany you have there because
today the market already rules
and
you know you give me i'm also
page one of google without paying google for
it if  you date smell a plaster or
best perfume i sometimes come in
first place because i
'm a google sheep like youtu  be and the
bank not in first place anyway
real marketing so
you can't spend money at all so
I don't give for applicants and if you didn't
know it to all the seo people out
there you will be mixed if you
pay for your content so if  you on
youtube the ozawa schein there
i come to boom boom and at the bottom comes
josefa schmid 30 million clicks i
have from me is only 800,000 but mine
are all organic and google ranking
fell this year if you hate real nice
clicks and not bought clicks we  are
a content strategy is there something
i talked about that you have
mackerel for breakfast because you
should always eat five eggs before every meal
and
nutrition
tips there are fitness tips there are all the perfume
the money what
[laughter
] dad v  so where could you rate papa
and tell me what's
good not so you can't smell it either
and logically but there is
in  the thoughts behind how you produce content
yes and no well i have the rule that
i have to do perfume-related things
back to the day well i make
at least three youtube videos a day
and at least three social media videos
a day and at least three photos a
day
the new content of the entire site yes
and i told myself the
codex it must be relevant to perfume
but the temptation was of course close
because you also earn money doing
a little bit of time then
strictly for a little bit of a year
i smell the go  I dance a bit
but if you sort of add it but the
content strategy is perfume relevant
and then I just mix in what's
currently in the area I
'm in Ibiza by the pool right now and I have a
six-pack then I'll work it in
somehow you have to work it out like you do
yes also only so what is
probably surprising for many only when
tags so now nothing would not a
second time  so record everything uncut
and that's his principles yes because
as florence you say to yourself at some point i
want you to
like me the way i am the way we all
kind of wish and then you say
you don't even come on mondays and that saves money
also time and i thought to
myself i want to be so good that you watch my
videos as montag because the
attention span is so short
meanwhile three seconds
fast i have to short-circuit you in the
brain of the animals to continue hearing i
like to learn i have to be so good  that
they listen to me without me having to
edit ok and you know what, no
police or how
do i do it myself but i want to have a
sonata video guy first in
germany it would be a kind of 450 euro
basic guy from the uni or nothing
the school that
can also show really cool videos and young blood is also
really good in the creative city so i
want to have support but that
would be it  americans do okay okay
because the market and the whole
dynamic is better there i want to live and
that's it so i'm
not in such good shape financially that
i have to artificially respect myself and
so and rather less than more in this case
and i'm much hornier  rattled when
I didn't have anything and that's why I'm
voluntarily now I'm going to the rail
and man but you have you that's
also very exhausting as it is then tag there
now to do all the videos that's
right now she advises  work is work yes
but it's fun it's fun for me and
what's what is the alternative yes
that's why a balance is
really a job so that you always have the office
job or something like that wouldn't be for you of
course logically office job
wouldn't be anything for me but it  not bad either,
i would also like to say that
the balance is also important work hard
play hard
and according to the motto i
'm radically intoxicated and then
ic regenerates  I'm also full of it and
then when I've fasted for two days
then I'll sit there on my third
day after I've trained and
then sit there but I eat
a kilo of dates with my eyes closed
and
do nothing for three hours as he sits cross-
legged  I make
222 dates, for example,
that's no fun and I have a six-pack
and the next day because the
glycogen stores are completely empty and
so the word yes, there can also be 1000 can he
can eat 1000 carbohydrates if
a glycogen teacher isn't fat
and don't need it  but be
careful not to imitate the complicated thing i'm
crazy by now so one
thing that also catches your eye do a little
research there are
now a lot of reactions to
the videos waldo is so unusual and
because he's so often horny without end there is
now somehow as  brand in general there
is the justin, for example,
i think the most successful, so to speak,
fragrance action vid  eo percent is that
do you even know each other or is there
a relationship we don't know each other
funny way i saw justin mai
at window shopping in düsseldorf at
rolex watches he looked at the
rolex watches and i
also went for a long walk there but otherwise have
we had never seen each other had our
own fashion label peso means
so probably not all of
them know it but a lot of them a bit
along the lines of how nvidia creates with xp and
so the or the kodi in los
angeles seems to be a very well known type
i shouldn't know it at all  but these videos
and I think that somehow say what
would have cured it and make it funny and make
action videos and
sometimes they really go on with millions of how
it goes on and that's the coolest
editorial advertisement if
I'm not in the picture I don't pay a
cent  for or at the general anzeiger
express in north rhine-westphalia that's
yes i don't pay 36,000 euros
for the ü  talk about me that
you do free of charge or partly i get
paid for an editorial thing which
is of course just awesome without end
or
thought content so it was based on the
motto what could work there now
or what could they pick up particularly well
but that seems to be the case
everything seems to you all the time at
the emi to arise out of
itself
at least yes they arise
very spontaneously that's true more
provincially clear because how that means they
were somehow allowed to but what what
I mean yes daniel schütz actually
then I was  in the boy band because the then
artist names one was called ali ahmed
ali called him then he
suffered another marc bartl the study for
a zdf and called himself jesse and
then we said you can also have an
artist okay what's my name like i
said jeremy  williams the surfer
in hawaii because my brother moved here at the time
i was in am for the first time in
my life  follow erika on hawaii
ends abercrombie & fitch store
and that sounded a bit like a
wave and jeremy and blabla and then when
the trees were over i said how
should i call myself now no longer
jeremy williams but i am the
journey of my own accord  and talking about
fragrance is now called chemistry
frankens supergeil you can only
recommend it
i heard i don't know if
that's true but that the human brain
is still
programmed in such a way that you
can only imagine 50 to 70 faces and
can remember names so who is the number
one
chef in the world gordon ramsay who is
the hamburger nutritional locks in the
world no idea and who is the type
that want me the people is easy to
do the branded up i am the
type for perfumes and stuff  are there
competitions there are other people
who don't have a chance now
so there are i'm a bit
like ronaldo he should be because the others
are lo  cker ten times as small as you
know really from they say well
I'll just came in here some
colleague had applied
and then asked you for fun too you
smelled you could then prefer the scent
I already next to it made me
okay that was now  no effect so you
will i wouldn't just
stumble in now you really know
everything about the topic correctly there are
the coaches incompetence that means you
don't know that you're stupid and then
there's the coaches incompetence you know
that you're stupid  wyss but change then
there is the coaches
competence that means you have
to look at the recipe beforehand how do I cook again
how do I get there and then there is
the core competence the highest level
you no longer have to look at the recipe
that means I have all of that  [ __ ] went
through all of them should smell
i learned from kardamon war from
guatemala and the vanilla comes from
madagascar i have it  learned all that dry
[ __ ] and that's in now
and the float just like that what is
the most successful professional in the world the
most successful is of course
chanel number 5 the most successful men's fragrance
who then accordion by the way from my
she you put it in the
united emirates here this is
jelen anne  are you the longer or
funny i had to call you back right away
you also want me a shop in dubai that's
right that's
ok i'm in the middle of the podcast but
i greet you and yours should also i'll
call you back right away yes
yes yes that was a probably have one
russian woman who lives in dubai in the burj
al arab and every own perfume brand
who wants to invite me to dubai that
suits me of course because i
want to soak up some sun
cool but
maybe a few words about the way is
but campaign we want to understand a bit
only then somehow now
you half created this giant, these giants,
this giant, but in the end it
was war  it was definitely
crucial that the people gave money to
do it before I
didn’t do anything and was
able to finance it myself you have to produce about 10,000 that’s about
ten
euros I have to put in 100,000 and then
we thought  why shouldn't we
actually know beforehand what
the resonance is like and then i used the
help of my brother, yes, the
internet is also on the go and
yes, why not i had the people because
we had a conversion rate of 10
percent i had  back then 500,000
subscribers and 5 percent 19 percent of
my people bought so more than
5000 people and that was pretty awesome
so yes what
kind of kickstarter he already had the alarm clock going we made
25,000 euros
as a goal so to speak and
we collected over 700,000 so
i started  phone london with
the guinness book of world records
and then i have to pay more than
5000 e  pay eur a month or just
once i can't even
remember squeezing for two years that's a
world record it's that cool but we
didn't do it but without
this claim it was just
hot crowdfunding france done
so to speak simply with printed online
what surprises me from the outside is that of
course there are a lot of people there
but that this target group is also able to
pay 2,300 euros for a few at the same time because you think
they are mainly younger people
tik tok also people who  on these half
stand but so people who now
pay a few more these are
probably often people who
go to work somehow
they don't have the
time to deal with the jobs right now but nevertheless
it seems somehow
you get there very well  wealthy people and
not just young fans now that's
true i know that people who watch my
channel also pay 300 euros for an or  t
pay for the one you wear i was already
aware of that unfortunately i am also aware that
we humans are so stupid and
to beat if there is a radical discount i
would have sold this fragrance for 120 euros
and you pay 120 euros for it
if the resonance is not so good  how hey
the scent later costs 160 and you
only pay 120 now that's how we humans are
unfortunately that was also the
pricing thing back then with my meager
amount of such I take what would
actually be fair nine Germans or
really fair ones make 39 euros they
gave me one  barbecue evening said i
'm worth more than 39 euros perfume
thought about is actually true when i
see the scent now it costs 229 euros
don't want to see douglas on sale for
149 i also say horny horny horny as
if the same scent and i know
it so that's how it ticks  unfortunately what the
target group can understand who
so how you than that we are again
the alta distribution we are men and
women distribute so main  Seriously men
who are 21 to 35 years
interested men who are interested in buying it was difficult
because most men are not that
interested in beauty men who
buy beauty products class technology and fitness but
beauty not so quickly and on which
platform there is the best so
conversion was the highest install
on youtube where there is risk most
sales youtube clearly was youtube is
the most loyal fan base but wait i
know when i think about
it i once knocked out a discount on tik tok he basically gave
me a whole house
because i
knocked out the discount
so it was  then bought so much yes
because so many see i was three
million people let it be only one
percent of them are yes 30,000
30,000 times
10,000 yes but I have an average or
value of 124 euros or something like that with me
yes because I have that too by
now  ten milliliter bottles and 50
meters and 100 milliliters so they
don't just buy the big sc  limping
but also the little
ones are crass
there is somehow that I ready or
that you talk about the
business about your whole thing that sounds
like you do what you feel like
but somehow you
probably need someone who is
a bit like that  coaching gives
what makes my partnership what
are they what is what worth also
all this logistics and so we
ask before there are questions that have arisen i learn
from people like the head of marketing at
chanel who tells me
janelle still really wants to use his cell phone
become warm who black and white there
are no questions red ferrari golden
growth i learn from people in the
industry give said ten milliliters i
would recommend you then i learn
from the director of purchase from douglas
yes the magic limit is 49 euros
for the  people that's a magic
limit 49 euros okay so you're learning but
at the same time i'm also learning from other
industries there  it's called
leonardo da vinci's boys don't teach anything
or anything like that because i've read his book
and then your brain
puts it together and like creative building blocks
so don't just be out and about in your field,
but i've also seen
a great inspiration from them  frame it
's a superstar then but yes there are
many great people arnold Schwarzenegger
so
yes but i also find all the
business questions right up to the
wehrmacht an accountant company
is now within a few years
a few months at the end from 0 to 1
million sales is possible and you do everything
yourself, mistakes can happen,
so that’s all, yes, mistakes also happen,
but because
materialism is not so
relevant to me now because I want to
dare to work on my family now and I,
oh come on, I’ve just reached it  a golden
rolex is enough, a woman will be
enough for me because i know what it's like
to have several wives and that's why ic  h
feel a bit of respect because it
's too easy to live in abundance that's
why I don't
care so much about sales we don't make it that bad
but I want to have more fame that's
cool I don't like it so if
the offers came in any way
what to do with with big partners who
give the reach yes i think that is great
yes is there anything currently in the planning
or did you have something like that since the partners worked
with him yes i have
yes i had such a netflix pitch
that they had me  was introducing netflix i
'm here and there for let's dance and
the bachelor i'll be
featured everywhere ok should i do it should
i not do it i reject that
now with galileo shooting and stuff
but who knows what will come of it or not
so  you would do it on tv
so if the year comes and
somehow the
dsds jury says or something will do
that i could imagine
doing that i can't say now that
m  al would but i
could imagine getting a bit more
reach and
you don't work with brands anymore
because you do your own things now
or is he i still
work with brands it's not that much but
if then  very highly paid and
there are only about 5 unfortunately we have it
in america we have l'oréal in
france we have the louis vuitton
group in france we have the
spaniards with push who have all the sexy
brains like paco rabanne and jean paul
gaultier and  we are not allowed to
let me call it the germans
that's one of the worst rich german
families called the reimanns
they mostly own them
who somehow made a
deal with kylie jenner yes and that's it then
actually so with whom you study
and with other luxuries  boarding is
just like rolex ferrari it makes things
so easy
i don't have any deals with them because i think they're
too cool to do them now
n Well, I
once invited them to Ferrari, but
I shouldn't persuade them because
I shouldn't
say officially where I am with them, because that was
one of their biggest rivals, well, ferrari doesn't give a [ __ ], they're
so superstar,
but I love them  you now have a
cooperation with youtube, for example
, it’s about the fact that
they want to win you over for it, i think this
new tik tok format as youtube shorts,
they also want short formats,
bonuses, how do you
spur yourself on from where I
I know that I said that
we have now
yes I always have what you say
here yes yes to brought a friend
of the house finds and recommends more and more people for more
yes so topic how
can you do it so I'm happy a
sheep  being from google and youtube
they offered me a great deal
to push the shorts a bit
on youtube we sometimes have
a chance mi  lllion clicks and that's going to be
the algorithm bush that
's quite good
and yes what would I be without youtube I
have I'm glad I bought the shares
from you too I love the one
so google shares shares
was that you bought it there I have everything
at no time was everything crowned because
i actually wanted to buy my ferrari
back i only had around
so i just had the money
to buy the ferrari bad i wanted to
show you and he didn't want to sell it
because he wanted to upgrade to the better one
ferrari but was afraid
that because of kohona he wouldn't have the money
to buy the special
he said then don't sell it back here
and i said okay
i'll invest everything in shares it was like 160,000 euros
or something like that yes  what do you think
again was standing
now now i'm reading
rosario's book the changing world order and so
always curious who the next
world will be  i did
n't even know it used to be amsterdam london
then it was now i think it's new
york city outfits next the
next capital of the world who will
be i think that's saying and let's
say generally investing that means you
're making stocks you're making a problem  did
you then tell other
things that you do gold stocks so
but
hadn't said yet that
somehow all the
attention you have the target group there
you could also do a fts like good
things yes i have my team
right there  start are those who are
very familiar with it and even so we have in
virtual fragrance monster we have
everything and all that stuff but i know
what it's like to live in the virtual world
i've played warcraft on
vacation before and all i can say
to everyone is power  the [ __ ] doesn't buy you
virtual buildings or stuff like
that it's so stupid old Swede do
n't do it people better be the
supe yourself  rstar i know how it is a level
60 paladins because all the night elfs
were
told something i will be my own night
elf it's much nicer not on
my own fifth avenue which i can
really breathe in because i have the
feeling people are walking slowly in that
direction
[music]
we don't need that yes what is
n't an issue for you that dreams don't and
is that a conspiracy i don't know
if
people are slowly
snatching away the real goods from people the real right goods
and a bit of brainwash bierhoff the
gallery  has the thing and then
traders you caught me your real physical
good i would be careful people so watch
out with too much
stuff and i think the dollar is just
awesome and if it all works out i don’t
give a [ __ ] because i need the materialism in a
similar way and i feel better
I will have nothing but when I have a
lot so actually only winwin what
do your parents say also agreed
that you are  that's normal behavior
is when you hear what you're doing
ferrari's golden rolex
partnerships i
'd love to know your old classmates we'd like to know because
somehow in a
school we met rené or something
higher than the speech in oldenburg he says urs done
than he is yet  I
didn't stay I was now a little bit
Neuchâtel my home and three four
months well but I can only
tell everyone that I'm a little bit involved
with it at the beginning when you start such
a crazy idea it's very
volatile so anyway a plant that's
straight  grows it can quickly
buckle from everything if someone says it's
deep in the [ __ ] then you can
sometimes keep it a bit to yourself for
the first few months
and if it then bears fruit if it becomes a
branch or a whole tree then
you are strong  you can say enough to everyone
and yes they will say yes for sure now
but there were also times
when you said if you didn't work that
people say yes we now it
works but not on that's why
everyone says that what you do is awesome and
i also support them all
financially now it's just that easy
mostly it fits but that's
the nice thing about the family because i
also pay my brother
and of course it's kind of cool
because it stays in the family alone
agency
the family and stuff and he's
by the way with quick quick learning for
consumption after the now also crass
on the go with the whole wreath and
sometimes you just think in the
videos what things come out and we
have a
detour it becomes money yes the thing is
who everyone is yes a bit
yes anyway a bit trapped
let's call it a philipp poisel we
know these singers on this
type philipp poisel  and i had the
feeling that a guy like him
was always a bit
closed but closed but when you put
him on stage  ch then it opens
up and so we are often a bit
hemmed in and there and here I can
be if you are here I can be
because I am and even now in the interview
I think about what I'm
actually doing but we're really free
on  usually either when we are
alone or when we reveal our art, so to speak
, as a singer on
stage or as an artist in a work of art
and so i just put out unfiltered
in my videos what i just got
out what is that supposed to be the
best video i made  I know
what works best well the
best video I've ever made is
now that
women video simply video about women
should funnily enough but as a child
actually always about sexy
fragrances compliment fragrances should
bring the compliments always in
English of course on youtube and
which one  fragrance brings the most
compliments my fragrance office for men
[laughter]
so apart if  at home you should have something
different you still recommend what that
was clearly the usa what you ca
n't do wrong the orange
otherwise what you can also do
there are small things about the celebs
buys from lukas podolski i
should at least have sent mine
nobody has  asked should
recommendation but then I said I'll
send you mine should otherwise so
so Argentinian superstar has mine
should I don't know but
somehow at record label superstar
messi I don't watch anymore
I had the chance shortly before the
title mine should  to give but
mine should be his himself
that's why i see his house from
my apartment in miami but also the
weir so blatant but
anyway your life can
change too like that will smith says to best
friends of the world the
fray checkpoint that has  him now 13
seconds takes another 16 seconds
on it and posted
so much i can't produce
like w  ir generated sales again through this post
now she
asked for it no no that didn't happen
but something like that can happen that as an
inspiration for people i notice it
sometimes when people make reaction videos about me
how it then goes through
the roof  goes and so in this
digital world it's an
unnatural
being and of course
scaling the internet
ok well i think you have understood extremely
well what all the
crazy things internet can do what kind of CVs are
there that will probably
never be possible without the internet
but  it's fascinated and i
think people enjoy it and let themselves be
inspired by it and in the end also a
consultant to me you also have an
inspiration but at the same time you should also be able to give
advice you also
simply have an idea of the matter yes right what
e recommend to me
I would recommend molecule 01 because
it's a scent that's different from
others and from Germany  nd and namborn
ok ok is different than others from
germany so i now like
and i hope we have to talk today
that would be it but heard that
ok i urgently need to see the guy live
we want to persuade you on may 17
18 too  in hamburg for the air festival
so we're working on it because he
'll hear from us then but that's some
unusual big successful digital
personalities and that would of course
work because
i'm coming back with you right now i'm not an
american yet and somehow all the
wealthy people say  again just for
info i don't know if it's worth it
no ami doesn't make a green card and so
i already have two companies there
because of you then have such a world to control
so and then we don't know each other
that well but that's why i have  just
my three months like its america i
click there now we are recording right
now in march may if i
would go back so pass
make that possible
thanks  that you were there it was extremely
refreshing and fills the openness and
i think you can understand very well
how you text and very excited i
'm excited and thank you very
much for letting me do this
and
that i'm just grateful to no
end  old swede that i can
sit here and do this with you
it takes a lot what you are all
involved and
thanks
[music]